thank you
[Music]
welcome back to care for boys we are
very careful boys and today we have Cam
we have Walter can you recently had an
experience with what some call
Ayahuasca it is what it's called I think
everyone some call it that so what's up
with what's up with it what's up what
was your experience yeah what's up with
it okay what drove you there and then
what happened before you even started
what compelled you to do such a thing
first let's take it back to when I used
to live with Joe you guys remember when
I used to live with him in Whittier
unfortunately was that a 2016 2017 yeah
about so yeah so the timeline starts
around
2016-2017. I was still kind of figuring
everything out because like dance was
kind of slowing down at the time and so
I was a very in a like experimental
phase of my life just trying acid trying
all this [ __ ] right and then DMT kind of
came into the loop to catch up Walter uh
can used to be in a dance group called
periodics they won which season on
abdc's Best Dance Crew season five
unlike hinges they actually won yeah
that's all you gotta remember so he was
like he was like Crush watching it and
then I think he's trying to figure out
like where he was going to take the next
phase of his career because like dancing
is pretty inconsistent anyway I was like
in that phase of my life where I'm like
yeah let's just do whatever you know
figure out what I want to do and then I
did DMT and then I tried that and that
kind of made me experience what it was
like to die but just for like five
minutes what's the difference between
the two because it seemed like they're
interchangeable so it's the same
chemical but uh DMT you smoke it right
it's like a white powder you smoke it
and then you just kind of sit there and
then you go through the trip and then it
ends in about like five minutes because
your body breaks it down really it
metabolizes it super fast does it feel
like five minutes no it feels like like
kind of like longer so is it like
Inception where you're in the world but
then it was only like two minutes yeah
it's like you're dreaming but then you
wake up and you're like oh I'm back here
you know when Ellen Page is stole a
trick and so what I saw in that deal
yeah
dude she was I think anyway I just saw a
lot of patterns like a lot of
geometrical shapes and I was like okay
that's kind of cool so this is what it's
like to die and then after that I kind
of just forgot about it and then later
on I I heard about Ayahuasca and I was
like what's that and it's basically DMT
but it's two plants it's this
Ayahuasca Vine which is the main thing
and then this leaf and those two things
go together to make this drink and
instead of smoking it you're ingesting
it and this time when you mix those two
things together it actually slows down
the process of breaking down the DMT so
it stays in your body way longer it's
like for hours and so imagine like
experiencing death and then like
whatever it is that you go through
because everyone's experience is a
little different like imagine just
experiencing what it's like to be dead
and then waking up from that it was like
the most trippiest thing but anyway
you said like it's like experiencing
death like so how do you know it's death
like it's like do you also Envision
someone strangling you or like it could
be it could actually be like that so so
here's all right let's just fast forward
until I found a place where I could do
um Ayahuasca like I found like one of
those Retreat centers yeah it's like a
retreat it's technically like ran by a
church but you have to have that kind of
legal you know setup is it Baptist or
like no it's nothing where's it located
uh what's the ZIP code it's different
every they hold it in different
directions is it close to a chicken
restaurant
no it's out in the middle of nowhere
anyway uh this one was in Temecula so
it's next to a wine place actually yeah
it did kind of look like that everything
in Temecula is next to winery yeah and
so it was a super beautiful Ranch you
know and then everything was like super
nice and we're just at this property
that the Airbnb for this ceremony and
then um there was a shaman there there
was people assisting musicians there's
just a bunch of people there just for
healing or whatever purpose you know it
could just be for like an experience or
whatever for me it was for the
experience because in my head I'm like
well I don't know what I really need to
heal from because I do know what my past
traumas are or whatever growing up but
let me just do this because it may
unlock even more that I'm not aware of
like I might have something like
blocking me that I don't even know and
so when I did it the first day and this
is a three-day ceremony oh you didn't
want a dog you get [ __ ] up for three
days so yeah three times yeah I did it
three times and in one night you could
do two cups so it's like one cup is
already a lot right anyway how many
hours is it uh it depends it depends
like the first night was like [ __ ]
like three four hours maybe five hours
but it started like at 10 pm so imagine
like you're supposed to be sleeping but
you're like [ __ ] going through this
whole crazy thing it's because the
shaman chooses when to do it because he
he goes off of his intuition he's like
okay with this group of people I'm gonna
do it this time and then whatever feels
right and the cool thing is he's the one
that cooks the Ayahuasca like the drink
and so he cooks it a little bit
different every time depending on how
he's feeling and so it it's supposed to
be intended to like uh for him to kind
of heal certain people in a certain way
for that specific night so even if you
do it this night it's gonna be different
the next night and the next night
because I know some people come with
something they want to work on yeah like
for you for the experience but some
people they go I have this purpose like
either like uh my best buddy died in
Afghanistan with me or like my my uncle
like beat the crap out of me as a kid
and I hate him I don't know or whatever
like and they're trying to work on
something yeah reject you sometimes if
they feel like you're not ready because
there's a screening process that you're
supposed to fill out and I forgot what
it's called but anyway you fill out this
thing on the internet like a form and
you have to list all your like medical
history and all this on this because
they don't want to be like they're like
diabetes yeah because if you're like
prone to like schizophrenia or like uh
psycho psychosis or anything like that
like you don't they don't want to risk
anything happening like if you're on
meds for like you know that type of
stuff and you go off of it and you're
all [ __ ] up you probably shouldn't be
going to the ceremony this is this is
like an option where it's more holistic
where you feel like you've tried
everything and you're like all right I'm
gonna try this now you know where you're
still kind of like
I guess
in in control of your own decisions
because sometimes sometimes people are
too far deep where they like they don't
really know what's wrong and they've had
people like that a ceremony where they
would lie on their intake form and like
oh I'm not on any medicine but then they
are and so [ __ ] happens right and the
thing is like you're supposed to sign it
and saying like this is truth so it's
not their fault if you know something
happens right because they're still
grounded in the real world with legal
Pro like yeah or whatever the
interesting thing I learned about
Ayahuasca is it's I think uh the
medicine itself is illegal for like to
sell and to uh distribute or whatever
right there's something legal behind it
where I know DMT is illegal I'm mostly
skipping this part of the video what
what part of the
Ayahuasca experience like opened up for
you like like how do we get to the part
where you get on it oh okay so first day
you want to just tell you what yeah walk
us through like take us through the
portal yeah
okay cool anyway so here's the part all
right
I sit down on my mat everybody's like
legs side by side in this beautiful
ranch we're just sitting there and then
the shaman goes hey everyone you know
this medicine is not a miracle all cure
type of thing it's a tool for you to
heal yourself but the ultimate tool is
you like you have to ultimately face
your own [ __ ] and deal with your own
[ __ ] the medicine just opens it up for
you to see it like whether you want to
walk through it or not it's up to you
and then he prompts everybody and then
um everybody goes up takes their cup
drink it and then the cool thing is he's
like
um he does this thing where he blows
into the cup his intentions for you so
he's he looks in you in the eye and he
goes okay
and then he gives you the cup so it
could be something like okay I want this
person to like work on this or whatever
whatever you don't know what his
intentions are but whatever it is in
there is what you're gonna feel that
that's the crazy part to me so anyway I
took the cup I sit down on my mat and
I'm just like sitting there I'm like
okay I don't see anything yet and then
like about like maybe 10 15 minutes like
things start getting a little wavy right
like any have you ever done psychedelics
it gets like a little shroomy here yeah
yeah but a little colorful yeah but just
uh keep in mind this is night time it's
like 10 p.m right now and and I'm just
sitting in the dark you know it's
outside the weather's perfect you're
Outdoors yeah we're Outdoors you're
under the stars yeah we're under the
start it's [ __ ] beautiful and then I
sat there and then I'm like oh [ __ ] like
it's starting to really kick in and then
I'm like you know what I'm just gonna
lay down close my eyes and just
experience it and next thing you know I
start seeing the same [ __ ] I saw on DMT
when I was like oh there's a lot of
fractals there's a lot of geometry and
whatever and it's like super interesting
like looking into a kaleidoscope almost
basically yeah so that's like just the
first layer and I every time I open my
eyes I'm like dude this is not the same
place I was at like when I closed my
eyes it like it looked like completely
different place so I'm like okay
something's definitely off here I'm just
gonna experience it for whatever when
you close you're laying down closing and
then when you opened it every single
time it was a different place no like I
was still at the center or whatever it
just looked so different like a
different version of it I basically put
on these lenses where it's like the same
place but it's different your
understanding of it's changed yeah like
my reality of it is like starting to
break like like the walls and stuff
didn't look like this anymore it was
something different because you're under
like a hallucinogen you know what I mean
so it's not gonna look the same but my
awareness was still there I knew that
this is just the medicine taking its
effect right and then after like 30
minutes or an hour passed by me just
kind of tripping out Shaman goes all
right everybody second cup and I'm like
oh [ __ ] oh my God okay let's go and then
I got up did the second one could you
even walk when you got up or is it like
barely barely I was kind of like oh [ __ ]
like I'm still here I know I know where
I'm at but it's like a little different
now because I'm under the medicine and
so when I got up did the same thing went
back down and then
you know wait a few minutes start to
really kick in and then I was just like
out
and at this point without me like I just
I'm unconscious holy [ __ ] so the weird
thing is in my head what I was
experiencing was I'm laying down I'm
going through this world of like just
[ __ ] like shapes right and then at
some point all these shapes just break
everything breaks and I'm just at this
place where I'm like I don't know where
the [ __ ] I am it feels like hell or it
feels like Purgatory or like some realm
where like there's beings here that I
don't even know what the [ __ ] going on
and then I'm just like super confused
yes this is my favorite part what are
the beans look like I don't know it's
like always constantly changing it's
entities right and a lot of people claim
they see these entities when they're on
um Ayahuasca but for me I was just like
ignoring it I'm like do you know that
you're high or are you just like you
know sometimes you're so deep in a dream
you don't even realize you're in a dream
until you wake up I knew the whole time
I was in the dream yeah and I knew that
like I'm supposed to be looking for
something right because I'm like what am
I healing from what am I doing here you
know and the whole time I was doing that
I was just going through like a bombard
of like crazy sounds and sights and
colors and like just [ __ ] happening and
then at some point I started seeing my
memories like I basically jumped into my
body from when I was younger and going
through all that trauma reliving it and
literally seeing it Replay in front of
me but all at the same time which
because there was no sense of time it
was just all happening what to deal with
yeah and it was just showing me like oh
you know how my parents used to fight or
like uh relate relationship problems or
whatever right and I'm just like damn
this [ __ ] is like super sad you know but
then I'm just watching it happen right
were you crying I think so here's the
I'll get to that part later like
everything that I was experiencing in
that world was it seems so real but at
the same time I was like okay what's
next I just kept moving through it and
at some point it felt like I was in it
like at literal hell where I could hear
like goats and like [ __ ] the devil
and like demons and all this like the
worst [ __ ] you could ever think of all
right it's got Tom Brady talking to me I
got [ __ ] the devil and then
yeah it's a nightmare for me and so like
it literally felt like I was in this
never-ending nightmare that wouldn't
stop I was just thrown into it over and
over I'm like [ __ ] what do I do I guess
I'm you know whatever I'm just gonna let
it be and then
um
I kept seeing like images of like some
of my friends here and there right and
whatever and the next thing you know I
wake up is daytime and I'm like what the
[ __ ] I feel like you didn't even sleep
like I literally felt like I was
dreaming and awake the entire time in my
mind and then I I go I'm just like
sitting there I'm like what the [ __ ]
where am I like who am I like what's
going on like because I was out of my
body right and I came back and then I
went to the restroom washed up and I was
like as I was standing up I was like oh
[ __ ] like I have legs like it felt like
that like it felt like I haven't been in
my body in so long that I'm like trying
to learn how to walk again whoa yeah and
it was the morning it was the next day
yeah and I was literally trying to
figure out all right what am I doing
okay I need to go take a shower I need
to go to the restroom whatever so I went
over grabbed my stuff went into the
shower and then my friend was checking
up on me the one that invited me to the
ceremony he was like hey how are you
doing you good bro and I just looked at
him I was like bro what the [ __ ]
happened and then he is like I'll tell
you later so was he sober yeah he's one
of the facilitators so he walks around
and checks on people so there's a lot of
people to check up well that's kind of
cool you have like someone that yeah
you're okay they make sure you're like
you're not going through crazy [ __ ]
right and so he he tells me we have a
conversation that day and he was telling
me like bro you literally you got butt
[ __ ] dude that's crazy no like dude
one guy was trying to troll me he was
like bro like like you know your [ __ ]
dick was being sucked and [ __ ] I was
like bro don't [ __ ] troll me like
that because
dreadlocks at all so the [ __ ] wait
that didn't happen oh
um all right sorry continue but like
he's just this is what actually happened
right so when I was on my mat tripping
the [ __ ] out and going through all this
[ __ ] what was really happening in
reality was I was just laying there it's
peacefully sleeping and and to me so
internally you're crying and crazy [ __ ]
but in reality you're just like it's
just like sleeping yeah and then and the
crazy thing is apparently I threw up
right and I was like when did that
happen right like almost everyone's mat
has like a bucket or something so I
wasn't even conscious when I was
throwing up and my friend was telling me
uh he was telling me like yo bro you
actually almost died in real life I was
like how come he was like because one
you were laying on your back and you and
we noticed some stuff coming out of your
mouth so I was vomiting like this and
you're not supposed to do that because
you're gonna [ __ ] die right and so
they had to turn me onto my side to let
all the vomit out and then uh this guy
that was like a medic in the military he
was like checking my pulse and guess
where it was at it was at like 30 like
almost like near death like it was super
slow like he thought I was dying and
then in my head like uh like I felt like
I was alive or whatever I was going
through my [ __ ] but I was literally not
in my body like my soul was not even
there because my friend would be like I
can't can't right and then I would my
eyes would open and I would look at him
and then just go right back to sleep I
don't even remember that happening like
I wasn't even there like my [ __ ] body
was just a vessel at that point right
and so I was like how the [ __ ] did it is
this the same time when you died or is
that another time so yeah that's the
first time I died
because you told me that you saw
yourself die too so that's the third day
here let me let me get to this so so all
right so that's why you don't explain
Ayahuasca is for eight minutes at the
top yeah anyway so that happened right
second day I was already expecting like
oh [ __ ] I've got to make sure I sleep on
my side this time so I don't [ __ ] die
or whatever have my throat bucket right
here and whatever whatever and this time
was completely different I took the cup
and I was like aware and awake the
entire time like my eyes were open like
I couldn't even go to sleep and this was
also at night time and I was like yo
what the [ __ ] this is like weird I'm not
seeing [ __ ] but I still feel it too and
then I was like okay you know what I'm
just gonna stay awake and experience the
medicine while awake and everything was
super beautiful like nothing was
tripping me out like the music that they
were playing was like super great I felt
like I was at a free concert and and the
night was great and the same goats that
I was hearing in my other dream they
were actually real goats out there
because it's a ranch and I was like and
I was like I was like oh that's what I
was was hearing oh and then and then
when there was like coyotes and there
was chickens there's so many animal
noises I'm like oh my God that [ __ ]
explains the the hell that I was in I
was actually hearing these sounds you
know and and one of the worst sounds was
like people vomiting like like and those
were the demons those were the demons oh
that's the trip yeah it is a trip but
when I was awake for the entire thing I
was smiling I was like oh [ __ ] this is
actually like crazy how the same
medicine affected me super differently
the second day yeah I was like wow this
is so beautiful life is beautiful and
I'm like oh yeah I get it now you know
I'm in the moment and just enjoying it
right third day I'm like okay cool I'll
do it again like I already learned my
lesson you know and I took it and I'm
like okay cool
everything gets super scary again and
I'm like wait what the [ __ ] like how
come I'm tripping out again and then
this time I died again but this time I
felt like I was actually like [ __ ]
passing away like I'm like oh [ __ ] I
can't move I'm like trying to fight
death like that's what it felt like I'm
like dude my body's not working what's
going on were you yelling like help help
yeah yeah yeah but nothing was actually
happening it was like sleep paralysis
almost where I noticed like my body just
phasing like my vision just phase and
I'm like oh [ __ ] where am I going like
like I'm sinking into the ground and
these flies are all over my body and my
skin is melting like I literally felt
like I was dying like my body was just
disintegrating and then after a while I
was like you know what [ __ ] it I'm just
gonna die and then and then I let myself
die you let go I like exactly save it
for the Yelp review bro yeah I just let
it go right and then as soon as I did
that like my mind just transported to
all these [ __ ] different places I
kept seeing my friends I kept seeing all
this [ __ ] and then uh one cool thing to
happen was I saw one of my friends he's
like a former Buddhist monk I try to
reach out to him in the spirit world I
was like yo bro what's up you know
whatever but then um trying to dab him
up I didn't understand why it was him
specifically that I saw but there's a
reason why later so I woke up from that
kind of nightmarish of me dying and then
um took a second cup and then
that second cup was like I was like [ __ ]
I really don't want to take because I
just [ __ ] died I don't want to do it
again you know and then the shaman was
like no you have to come like he picks
certain people to take the second cup
and there's a reason right and and my
friend was like no just do it bro
because I was fighting it I was like bro
I just want to stay inside I want to do
it again you know it's scary right and
then he's just like trust me like when
he picks you you just have to go I'm
like [ __ ] okay I went up there he pours
me like a big ass cup and I'm like bro
no I'm not gonna take this [ __ ] and then
he's like I'm just kidding he poured it
out he just gave me a little bit I'm
like dude this guy's a [ __ ] jokester
bro and I'm like whatever and then I
took it and the same thing happened with
the second day where I was like oh [ __ ]
now I see why he made me take it again
because it's like I have to learn to
just not give a [ __ ] and just go with it
and go with the flow and Trust the
process that's what they keep saying
just trust him and then I once I did it
was like my reward cup like everything
was beautiful again everything was
awesome again and it was the last day
and I felt like super good and I was
like damn what a [ __ ] trip like I
just went I just [ __ ] died several
times came back to life okay you know
what I mean and it made me like go back
to my friends and go like oh [ __ ] like I
get it now like I get why I did this is
for me to understand that like whatever
I'm doing right now is like you just
gotta trust it and don't even think
about like fighting the process of
things you know what I mean again like
in your current life yes that's the
lesson
like are you gonna go on to Tony Robbins
and got on that yeah but the thing is
like I [ __ ] experienced it and I
never got to understand it until like
you know you know the lessons right I
know know these lessons already but when
you experience it and relearn the
lessons again and live through it it's
so different it's like it sticks with
you like way more and the cool thing is
like this is the type of [ __ ] that helps
people with PTSD with depression with
whatever whatever because it makes them
want to live again you know what I mean
because your mom said yeah yeah a lot of
military guys they end up after
psychology all this stuff they go to
Ayahuasca because they're just like I
don't know what else to do yeah a lot of
people talk about like uh like having an
ego death did you experience that or
what is it when I died I'm not literally
dying it's my brain just shutting off
like just trusting it the medicine just
take over yeah and like
I didn't feel the crazy part was when I
died in my dream like I wasn't even me
anymore like it was something completely
I was just experienced something but it
wasn't me anymore would you say like you
had some crazy insecurities or like
defense mechanisms that no longer exist
in you anymore yeah is there something
that you you didn't know you were going
there for but you found out you were
going there for it deeper than what you
said already so one of the things was
like my ex for example like I didn't
really think I was over the whole
situation because I was with her for so
long right and then when I was
revisiting it again I came out of that
trip going like man like I truly did
love her and I'm ready to like just
accept that and I'm never gonna hold
anything against her anymore regardless
of how I felt sorry after the breakup
it's like good closure good moving on it
felt like closure same thing family like
I know we went through so much [ __ ] but
now it's like I came back home first
thing I did hug my mom hug my dad
because I'm so happy to be alive yeah
but you don't hold on to the arguments
in the trauma exactly and and from now
on like I I try not to argue with them
but at the same time now it's like
cemented like I don't any small thing
now is to me that's nothing bro like I'm
not kind of give a [ __ ] about that
you've transcended in a way in a way but
at the same time
just when I thought I learned my lesson
of like oh yeah everything's great
everything you got to remember it's like
it the medicine just knocked me right
back down I died again and I'm like like
that's my other lesson too which is just
when you think everything is good just
remember like in the real world like
anything could [ __ ] happen at any
time like just when you think you're
good like just remember like [ __ ] will
happen and you gotta just take it you
know
Vietnamese Vietnamese okay so when you
went home and you hugged your parents
were they like what's going on yeah no
no no they weren't they weren't they
were why are you smell like vomit yeah
no no
um you know what the they're like did
you [ __ ] a shaman
why do you smell like holy water
no but yeah because like most Asian
parents like you know unless you
regularly hug them they're gonna be like
what's going on and then my next
question was is like did you explain to
them oh like I died several times no
because they wouldn't get it but the
cool thing was uh I did explain to them
kind of what the retreat was about and
my dad was completely interested in it
and I was like yeah you know like they
do this kind of medicine in the Amazon
and it's like very helpful for whatever
and I don't think they're ever gonna try
it I don't think they really need to
because already they're really spiritual
people if this was in the Amazon no this
was in Temecula oh no but normally
started
it helps you can pay attention to
everything he's saying and not just but
going back to Tony Robbins like this is
a type of lesson you can learn with
anything you can learn it with religion
you can learn it through meditation you
can learn it through you know going
through a seminar but like for me I've
been through all this other [ __ ] and and
it's like I don't really
find anything yet but when I went to
this it's just like hit some yeah
different things hit for different
things for different people right how
much does it cost uh it was like 850 for
three days that's cheaper than Tony
Robbins though yeah so when you if you
get two
is it like all included or are they like
yeah they feed you you know but like do
you think it's a premium yeah they
charge you after a parking pass do I
have to tip the guys when he's leaving
they're like hey you know everyone got
three but you got five so you gotta pay
extra like
than everyone else
yeah so I'm the only one thinking that
well there's like so he had more
breakthroughs than me like what the [ __ ]
is going on yeah what the [ __ ] I I he
got to [ __ ] his girlfriend one more time
which is kind of cool but you know
that's pretty much like my experience in
a nutshell there's like way more things
that like were going on in my head but
it's way too long for this video no
that's tight it's a lot that's cool no
honestly it's really cool that you can
delete so much footage and then like
still like find
like find like an even ground okay you
don't understand how bad I felt
yesterday I love you buddy I love you
I'm kidding
that's another thing it's like just want
to think oh yeah everything's going good
and [ __ ] this [ __ ] happens I'm like
why yep that's the medicine telling you
is the medicine bringing back down to
earth it's humbling you bro just make
sure you don't train Justin and Jason to
delete the footage
honestly and I'm not I'm not kidding
right now this we we did this to you
because we're we're gonna delete the
food
so you [ __ ] learn you're about to
learn a lesson we're just gonna delete
your camera
[Music]